- Jay Leno is currently walking through,
I mean he has a palace
full of, I wanna go to Jay,
I wish I was in quarantine
with Jay Leno right now.
(laughs)
That's what's happening.
Anyway, he's gonna take us
on a tour of his garage,
so here we go.
Wait, is this your garage at your house?
Is that real?
- Yeah, no it's not real.
Yeah, it's all an illusion.
Yeah, so, yes.
- No, I'm like, are you at a studio,
that's legit,
how big is your garage?
- No, this is my garage.
It's 140,000 square feet.
(Kelly laughing)
- That's awesome!
Is that like a restaurant behind you?
- No, we call that a kitchen.
- It looks like a little,
you should have a diner.
'Cause it's all cute with all the cars.
- That's called a kitchen.
- [Kelly] I know, you should
have Jay Leno's diner,
you should have the whole thing like cars.
(laughs) Oh my god.
He's still walking through huge places.
- Well you gotta come
by and see it sometime.
- [Kelly] Oh my god, I
want to come by and see it,
I have never felt more like
"Pretty Woman", you know,
in the store where you don't belong
and you know you're
trying to buy something
and like, you don't belong here.
Like,
(laughs)
That's amazing.
- I didn't know where
you were going with that,
okay, you're a hooker, and it's just--
(laughing)
it didn't make any sense.
- No I meant like when she does
a place where she doesn't belong.
All right where are you at right now, Jay?
- We're just crossing
into another building,
I want to show you,
I like cars that have
sometimes you buy the story
as much as you buy the car.
Like the cars I'm
standing in front of now.
These are both Hudson Hornets,
this is a 1953, it's a 1951.
I bought this one first and I restored it,
and then one day I got a call
from a 94 year old woman,
and she said,
I understand you like cars,
my husband and I bought a
brand-new '51 Hudson Hornet,
in '51 and we drove it from
New Jersey with our family
to our new life in California,
and he died in '96.
This is back in 2004.
She said, would you be
interested in buying the car?
And I said, well I already
have a Hudson Hornet.
She goes,
well, it's a wonderful car,
would you just come look at it?
All right.
So I drive up there, 94 years old,
no hearing aid, no glasses,
looks like she's 60.
So she shows me the car
and it's got four flat tires,
it'd been sitting for 20 years
but he died in like '96, this was 2004.
She goes, well will you
give me $5,000 for it?
I said, well, all right, okay.
So I bought it, I felt sorry.
Then I brought it back to my garage.
Took about two years to restore it.
And I figure, why don't I
see if she's still alive.
So I dialed the number and, "Hello?"
I go, hi, it's Jay Leno.
Oh Mr. Leno!
Now she's 96 and I said, listen,
I finished the car, it looks brand-new,
do you want to go for a ride?
"Oh I gotta get my hair
done, oh my god, I gotta--"
I said, yeah.
And she goes, can the kids come?
I go, well sure.
Well her kids are 74 and 72.
(laughing)
So we're driving along,
she's telling me stories about
you know, coming across Route 66
back in the '50s and what it was like.
Meanwhile the two kids in the back
start poking each other like this.
So she turns back, she goes, I don't--
(slapping)
She just starts slapping
the crap out of them!
Just whacking over the head.
And the three of them are just laughing
and falling down, they're just hysterical.
"I told you kids to behave,
Mr. Leno gave us a ride."
And she's just whacking
them and whacking them.
And the three of them
are laughing so hard.
And it was really the time of my life,
it was just a wonderful--
she lived to be 104 years old.
- Wow.
- But she had such fun going for a ride
in the car,
with the two kids,
and you know that's
what makes this car kind
of special, it's not really a special car
until you know those stories.
The only car they had,
and the 72 year old and
the 74 year old told me
when they were teenagers,
they were so embarrassed
that their parents' car
was 16 years old,
that they would have
their dad drop them off
like three blocks from the school
and then they would walk to school
so other kids wouldn't see
that their dad drove a 1951 car.
Of course now it's a
classic, but back then,
that was a whole different story.
So that's, you know,
that's a car with a pretty good story.
- Well can we see another
car you have in there?
- This is my '55 Buick Roadmaster.
When I came to Los Angeles,
I got off the plane at LAX,
I immediately went to the newsstand,
I bought a copy of the pennysaver,
that's like one of those
advertising magazines, you know.
You buy things for sale.
And I was looking for a car, 'cause in LA
you need a car before
you need a place to live
because you can't get to the
place you live unless you
have a car.
So I saw this advertised
at $350 and I bought it,
and I've had it since 1972.
I met my wife in this car,
we dated in this car,
got married in this car,
I took this car to my first Tonight Show
and I took it to my last Tonight Show.
I'll tell you the story,
my wife hates this story,
but it's kind of funny
'cause we had our first encounter
in this car,
(laughing)
- Encounter.
- Encounter,
and on our 25th wedding anniversary,
I said, let's try and recreate that.
So we both got in the car
and we drove to where
we had our encounter,
but now it's a housing development,
so I'm like, okay, I think
it's right where that house is,
okay.
We pull up on the street, okay.
And the house is like, right there.
So you're not as agile at 25
than you are at, you know, at 50.
And then it's all,
(squealing)
ow my hair, and then the horn's beeping,
it's like 2:00a.m.
(Kelly laughing)
I see the porch light come on,
the guy comes running out,
"What's going on out here?"
Nothing, nothing, excuse me!
So the second encounter
was not as successful
as the first encounter,
but we had a lot of
laughs, it was pretty fun.
- That's pretty much how
marriage goes though, right?
The second encounter's--
- What?
- Just kidding.
- Exactly.
- I'm just kidding.
No that's awesome.
I think you have found
the love of your life
when you can make out in a car.
I have made out with my
man in a car as well.
That's a sick car though,
that's a really cool car.
- A car like this, this is such a big car.
You don't even have a radio,
you just bring in live acts.
(laughing)
- They just play right there with you.
- [Jay] Yeah.
- All right y'all, we actually have a clip
of me and my driving skills with Mr. Leno
on his show, Jay Leno's Garage,
which you can watch on CNBC,
y'all check out this clip right here.
- [Kelly] Oh my god, I wanna know what
that underground tunnel thing was.
Yes, yes!
- [Jay] It's an actual goldmine,
it's been here for over 100 years.
- [Kelly] Really?
- [Jay] You probably shouldn't go in.
- [Kelly] Oh we should go in!
This looks pretty sturdy.
- [Jay] I don't know if it's safe.
- [Kelly] This is sturdy.
Oh my god it's pretty echoy in here!
- No I know it's echoy
but don't sing in a mine,
you're not supposed to.
(Kelly singing loudly)
(rocks crumbling)
(suspenseful music)
(upbeat music)
- All right thank you so much, Jay,
I always love talking to you.
- [Jay] You too, Kelly.
- Yes, everybody y'all watch
Jay Leno's Garage Wednesdays on CNBC,
especially my episode
which airs June 24th,
I'm an expert driver is all I'm saying.